hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's 3 now we've got a long way to go
and I know it's been a while since the
last one I apologize for that I have no
excuse for my behavior I think I've
already gone into the dark world over
here so I think we just need to go and
beat this night to death we need to
smash it in its face because this is the
fifth night and according to the name
this is going to be the last one so I'm
going to beat these guys faces in and
then slap them with their own corpses
don't ask me how I'm gonna do that my
momma take turns with them cats gonna
beat the mouse in the mouths gonna be
the cat anyway we're gonna beat this
blob Yuki come on what you got what you
got for me huh you think you got
something for me
no her that manners would be easier if I
was like the girl from the ring in my
head was just spinning round and round
or wait the girl from The Exorcist my
head was spinning on a goddamn swivel
preemptively rewinding is my friend and
that kitty cat is not my friend stop
that I saw you there you'd be bang
banging on the door again don't know how
you got in that closet go back to Narnia
and tell Liam Liam needs him to go [ __ ]
himself I don't know I I got nothing
against Liam Neeson oh not today you can
bang all you want it ain't gonna happen
huh this room is a bang free zone whoa
hey buddy boo ah [ __ ] you
snap oh snap crackle pop up [ __ ]
I gotcha Elsa does guess does is a
goddamn guess does a [ __ ] guess
oh hey let's see you over there yeah you
skedaddle back knocking out hi today not
gonna die today gonna live a live long
life no mouse is gonna eat me um our
grow up and be a youtuber someday okay
yeah I'll be like my hero market oh I
ain't good that's bad
well you came out of nowhere you weren't
there before we could come from where
did you go good night Joe you give me a
goddamn straight answer for once in your
goddamn life can you catch there too
don't play double duty you [ __ ] know
I thought I could play double duty [ __ ]
Gupta goofty good we got that goof gone
so now we just need to get the goof in
playing the goofer going we're almost
done with his son of a [ __ ]
5:00 a.m. should be right around the
corner which means that we're gonna be
in good shape right soon yep I am
okay one more hour if I got this on lock
I can stop being such a goddamn goof
about everything that I do I'll be able
to get through this
whoa where the [ __ ] okay all right then
he's goofing me pretty good
I feel goofed here there's some some
scenarious goofin yarn on goddamnit he
goofed me again [ __ ] your goofing
hammock god Danny give me good sky nice
give me off the goof train I can't take
this goofy goofy I hear a cat goofing up
on me how much care for the goofy of the
cat let's break it back down there
something Jim okay almost there I'm a
theremin sir if I'm lucky I can get 6
a.m. before I get another encounter with
a riot way right speaking of you go
screw yourself with poo
[Music]
[Applause]
okay now what weird cutscene is gonna
happen now how does this go bad
for me this is gonna be completely empty
no it's not it's not a oh alright then
I mean maybe it'll be empty after the
show starts and everybody dies everyone
dies a horrible yeah
can I you're on air now yet fine I sense
if there's got to be something else here
in these wow it's a crowded day today
full house
today's the day with the surprise show
excited to see what it's about
no dad because apparently it's going to
be deadly
whoo all the kids are so excited I'm
gonna go over here first though okay
nothing all right
hi hey calm down guys hey I have an idea
let's all play hide-and-seek together
I'll pay your encounter 100 while you
all hi ready set and go okay huh didn't
you hear what I said
you have to hide oh great ironing spot
okay
is there gonna be like no hiding spots
left and I have to Oh No
well where did all the kids go where the
heck the delhi whoa don't look back
whoa it's Winnie Oh Winnie ah
[Music]
hide in the closet maybe not it's
telephone it's the script for today's
show we are going to reveal the rat and
cats names it says here the cats real
name is candy candy the cat I kind of
like it
Oh five nights at candy's don't explain
it says diploma and something about
acting so many clocks is just boring
paper stuff to bees all right okay and
then let me check the trash can that's
the last thing anyway
there's two drawings in the trash bin
the first is of a boy in the puppeteer
with the words best friends with oh I
don't a kid who thought it was his best
friend ah doubt you're the drawings of a
boy and the cat also best friends well
they don't care about nothing I'm behind
this closet is gonna go good for me I
saw you walk in here kid I'm gonna find
you what are you thinking you're here in
that condition black man only had a few
you have any idea what would happen if
any of the parents found out if one of
our actors is drunk think of our careers
think of the children
what about the children they love me
the most popular character in this
freaking show I'll be jealous that I've
got Colin Udo
you have no idea where you talk about
take off that costume you're going home
no I'm gonna go back out there keep this
damn show alive hey Don Oh cut it out
oh yeah okay whoa hey let me go how dead
okay hey blue are you okay oh man this
isn't funny that blood isn't funny oh no
no no no Oh what with all that Oh what
happened
lock the door I didn't mean you it was
an accident I swear we just he we have
to call an ambulance and the police we
have to tell them what happened
no a blank was always been unstable he'd
been drinking found him like this yes
yeah yeah that's what it was yeah that's
what we have to tell them found dead in
here this it was an accident
an honest mistake we have to tell them
what really happened I can't I'll have
to kill you do to make you silent ring
ring ring ring ring OH
oh yeah that's a good move yeah it's
always the best move to do that are you
doing I can't breathe oh boy yeah I was
just joking about to kill him to thing
that was a joke you didn't have to do
that that was house the opposite of what
should have been huh yeah take one
second to stare at the diplôme please
you have to hurry over here
my core dad father I just prepared
something it sounded like a rustle I
just came in if they were both dead in
here mysteriously you don't understand
we run a theater the show's beginning
and the RAM cap here do you know where
it is
good yeah yeah okay I'll do that yeah
I'll tell everyone it's canceled today
okay no no my old copy there okay all
right there certainly is no little girl
hiding in the closet here no no way look
what are the odds of that happening okay
where does no boy wait would you like to
take the diploma I can take the acting
diploma you such a good actor that you
can't even remotely break character for
a second you murderous bastard well boy
are you sure that's what happened it's
okay Mary you remember now and that's
good now that you remember do you still
think it was your fault you weren't the
reason he did what he did he did those
things because of himself I'll help you
you're not alone in this you don't have
to be afraid anymore you don't have to
fear them and you don't have to fear him
either
you mean Finny do you think he'd be able
to describe the room to me maybe you
could draw it for me okay I'll do my
best I suppose I don't know if I can woo
the truth ending mary has definitely
improved and she's finally remembering
what happened it's exactly what I
thought
Mary had experienced something on the
same day as the incident her nightmares
stem from that same incident somehow her
unconscious mind blocked her memories of
the experience leaving only the fear
left except I never imagined it would
have been such a disturbing experience
Mary witnessed the incident from inside
a closet in the same room she remembers
it all clearly now she was even able to
describe the layout of the room with
detail I recommend that Mary should keep
seeing once a week until she's fully
recovered from her traumatization
miss Sherwood could you please schedule
a meeting with the authorities for me
ASAP I need to talk to whoever handled
the case they need to hear Mary
statements tell them what she was a
witness and that they should consider
reopening the case okay all right then
ah wait final night and then extra what
does it mean though let me check out the
extra first before I go to the final leg
oh wait a minute I didn't know this is
gonna be a game I thought oh okay oh the
making of monster rats
always start with the eyes when I model
characters I wanted the eyes to be as
wide open as possible to get X grid of
eeriness in my experience smaller and
more realistically proportion eyes can
make the face much scarier simple
reference lines nice using the rat as
reference yeah creepy whiskers which
haven't been mirrored yet some fair
separate object they won't get married
okay all right
interesting stuff spooky scary spooky
scary yeah I don't have much work in 3d
modeling but he definitely did a good
job in making this guy pretty flippin
scary hey ha hey okay I'm the arcade oh
okay oh I can't eat oh look
Candy's getting food then these would
have been cool minigames to have like um
I'm not saying it I'm not critiquing the
story at all it wouldn't do that like
the story was actually pretty good
but it did get a bit repetitive after a
while I feel like maybe there was a way
they could have sprinkled these in there
have these go by it would've been really
cool that trash is that gonna bad
oh no Candy's gonna die oh hey let's
tangu
it was Pangu I miss Pangu yeah now it's
not complete yet because I guess I
didn't get that one let me uh let me go
back to the main menu let me try this
final night let me try it I don't know
if I'm gonna beat it this time oh hey
how's it going why did you return here
the secrets arms the weight of your
guilt has been erased so why did you
return here
I guess you wanted to confront the
problem me the problem I didn't realize
what I had done until I was in my bed
about to sleep I was never able to think
clearly again I don't even know if it
still would have had if you hadn't been
there but you were there you saw it all
and now the truth has come out and my
life ends we'll never be like before I
had everything and if then you took it
away you don't get to walk away from
what you've done to me you've ruined my
life and now I will make sure you'll
never be able to sleep again ha ha ha
mookee
ok alrighty then the final night all
right Vinnie come on come at me if you
can I don't even know if you're able to
anymore are you up to the challenge of
the markiplier yeah didn't think so
hmm okay whoo the [ __ ] okay
Minnie come on out
play with me whoo ah it's a moose it's
the reincarnation of the moose man oh ye
[ __ ] [ __ ] you dude [ __ ] you dude [ __ ]
you dude whoa hey hi
how you doing you good yeah yeah why
don't why can't I just turn on my
bedroom lights oh god oh god oh god hi
okay so oh my god what was that oh [ __ ]
that's our deal with AA [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
okay you come down there sonny jim mini
the moose man oh [ __ ] you're [ __ ] out
of your goddamn gourd you i [ __ ] [ __ ]
you are you even doing ha back up
ah ah ah ah oh [ __ ] way am I just
gonna be dancing this dance all night
huh Phineas son of a biscuit eater
yeah sack of [ __ ] okay exactly then I
guess I'm eating okay hi was that the
cute baby
alright okay alrighty then
yeah I've been pulled back amnesia
[ __ ] goddamn mousse man is really
acting up a storm out there so [ __ ] off
ah [ __ ] well hi oh I thought I had that
I thought I was doing great okay then
[ __ ] you alright anyway so that is all
the time I got for five nights at
candy's there is some more to do here
and Vinny seems to be a bit of a
challenge here and there are more things
to unlock I didn't miss one of the
arcade games to play in the menu here so
there's a whole bunch of other stuff and
maybe I've got one more episode to do
the conquered Vinny once and for all and
see what the rest of these things are I
did until then thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think down the comments below and as
always I'm seeing you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]